[Music]
there's a question which is tearing our
community apart okay it's not tearing
the community apart but let's pretend it
is which is the best assassin skin the
new breathtaking Keanu or the og Reaper
which is the best John wick today we
will decide so sit back relax
use code Adam are you in the fortnight
shop and let's go to war
let's try the new John wick mode
together see what happened let's get to
this chest before anybody else
Hey did I would you we have weapons
drink it straight away
I had no II can't build no bills okay
right I've learned something
straightaway we have we have weapons to
get away but we don't have built
straight already had to happen foreign
children screaming
[Applause]
come on kid on the table we pick up the
way to victory at least anyway hey yo yo
hey I can hear everything I can hear
nature we're going to win now life is
good life is damn good
okay okay okay it's just me I've got no
squad mates but thanks very much Oh
didn't seem easy claps all right
I'll wait up top for you mate give me a
sec you do you think mate you bit look
at him
stealth genius he's gonna win the game
I can feel it oh no reverse card he's
using the same thing I'll one up you sir
might be hell did he go
well that was anticlimactic
I heard footsteps footsteps there is
[Music]
potato wave at your service it's a
squeaky kid still here he is isn't he
we have to win this for the squeaker kit
I didn't expect to it that we have this
creaky kid come on
squeaky foreign child this is for you
bro this is for you well that's too damn
low looks like we're playing defensive
all right count down with your traps in
the low play there so one full squad one
solo and me you know it comes you got 3
left now dudes what are you gonna do
what's your battle plan
[Music]
oh it noises don't you
oh yeah I can tipple better
his name was what I shouted at him okay
well I've got redeploy mate what have
you got
you're not gonna raise your friends whoa
calm down
right you've even got to hit me out of
the air oh I am winning this match nice
nice my god [ __ ] ah dang
come on dude you got this we didn't know
now that I've won this I don't have to
shoot we won it for the noisy kids and
remembering what he said at the start of
the game he gave his advice he said to
us was the advice that got us through
that game GJ's oK you've noticed me I
understand I get you it's all good
oh good Oh coach oh good English yeah
you two fight I'll be back in a minute
he's gonna drop down you mark my words
here he comes
you ready predictions I look like I know
what I'm doing there's the other guy
let's go see him again exactly same
thing I'm gonna wait here
I may be good but I'm very lucky too
come on who's next
we need to get some kills in if we're
going to win this you trying to follow
me bro oh yeah give me those coq10 coins
so I've got come on you need one of us
what kind of bowl I've got a bowl I
can't impose in my life
one quick boons like some nanny debt
before you die 70 thank you well like
you stay still mate some pilots not bad
we got a teacher speedster what would
Jesus do Jesus would go for more kills
I'm gonna get sniped get through get
through what is this made of steel well
well yes yes yes it is yes a mate I'm
being chased so can we make this quick
please are you in here no you're not are
you in here no you're not where are you
mate oh you're right there
the person who have chases me will stand
on that you muck oh oh oh he's got a
quick bill then it's gone lad hey good
bro
I want to watch this guy this guy's my
new favorite ok those Eddie's he's made
for this game he's my standard sorry do
don't need to get moving
cool story bro excommunicate Oh
excommunicate oh alright some second
which is the first loser so you love
being the first loser in life then you
do yeah G and then C C and B and you
were down almost almost
[Music]
boy I wish you grew up in my era
it's dumb ah ballsack I see you bush
hang on that's genius
can we hit the Bush once at least ready
watch this next shot boom watch this
watch this watch this
what's this for God's sake now you know
why I don't play for tonight can I hear
bloody barn door alright boss I need
something to reinvigorate anything still
can't hit anything I need to reset my
life yes you can
just doing the first [ __ ] where's your
brother from another mother yeah we're
back we are back we need a montage now
of all the shops there's no headshots in
the slightest
Ravi T okay
[Music]
boy this world
[Music]
legit the toughest shot ever did you see
that eat that D quarters
[Music]
we're back substandard sniping
[Music]
are you friend or foe I want to play a
full game without picking up a weapon
he's down he's down good lads he's down
with there and he's gonna father they're
gonna kill me aren't they stop following
me won't dance bro it's okay I believe
them good you're adopted I've just
wasted wasted three minutes watching
this guy cut down the field what a waste
of my life he's still going
we'll wait till his friend leaves it
would kill him come on bro let's see all
your friends come and help you come on
John wick thick versus these Oh where's
your friends oh yeah we look at those
90s wow check out those 90s Ally a would
be proud
yeah a nice brush their soccer skin oh
that's the last one gone dude you got
this you got how you really have okay
okay okay you literally just looting you
you're only losing 12 kills seven people
left we drop weak we don't build we we
we die oh one day I will learn to build
honestly we played this game for like
two years I still don't know how to
build
don't wake Victor so it's time for the
final battle to decide the greatest
Wieck skin but first check out these
bunch of leggings thanks you guys for
using code on tomorrow in the shop you
make these videos possible if you want
to be immortalized in a grenade video
please send me a picture on Twitter if
you use my code anyway it's time to
answer the ultimate question we had a
battle inside the Continental with only
John wick and Reaper skins to decide
once and for all which is the greatest
skin and here's what happened when you
hear the airhorn you can pick axe the
crap out of everyone until only one
survives don't do it until the airhorn
and the survivor I need you to emote in
the middle of the room afterwards okay
please don't run away and come out later
for this to work it needs to be a
complete slaughter I know I'm the first
to die the last
just needs to hit anymore and everyone's
dead so soon as you hear the air horn
what the carnage begin
[Music]
[Music]
the last man standing was none other
than Marvel fanboy rockin the new John
wick skin so that scientifically proves
John wick is better than the reaper if
you disagree come fight me in the
comment bro right enjoy the rest of you
week I'm Adam from Playstation grenades
spin a pleasure next time
[Music]